now I must admit this BT Awards a little
different main thing is it's virtual the
2020 BT Awards were committed to making
it work even during a global pandemic
we're getting real in touch with being
real inside because outside is all one
it's got Colvin and cops and Karen's go
Wow Amanda Steel's started off the 20th
anniversary show with a powerful
political message
now folks always say all Amanda ever
does is talk about race well listen I
would love to talk about regular
everyday things but racism always beats
me to it what she promised when we
talked to her last week we're seeing
artists who are just very seamlessly and
organically bringing in what's happening
in the world into their performances and
I'm doing the same thing with my comedy
and my hosting so really what we're
gonna do is what exactly is expected of
that folks we're gonna speak and perform
from the natural space where we are
right now as black Americans while the
show was filmed remotely something SEALs
made light of at the very end oh and by
the way I did do it in my house
the artists use their pre-taped
performances to their advantage
delivering nothing short of fire energy
and emotion the baby and rowdy rich gave
viewers a powerful blacklivesmatter
remix of their hit rock star the video
was complete with scenes directly a
voguing the recent protests and
struggles against police brutality and
racism Alicia Keys brought fans to tears
during her first live performance of her
heartbreaking new song perfect way to
die at least you'll stay forever young I
guess you've picked the perfect way to
die of course there was Megan Lee
stallion who was literally on fire
the 25 year old delivered a steamy
performance of her new song girls in the
hood and her hit savage remix complete
with Beyonce's vocals and so much
twerking and Jennifer Hudson singing
Aretha Franklin song young gifted and
black was everything J HUDs perfect
performance ended with scenes of her
portraying the late musical icon in the
first trailer for the upcoming biopic
respect which debuted during Sunday's
show how many albums have you before and
no hits
honey find the songs that move you until
you do that you ain't going nowhere as
for our 2020 winners Drake led this
year's pool with six nods though he only
left with one trophy and Megan the
stallion brought home two of the five
Awards she was nominated for but it's
eight-year-old Blue Ivy who nearly stole
the show winning her first beauty award
with Mom Beyonce and we can't have an
award show without honoring those we've
lost
Wayne Brady paid tribute to the late
Little Richard with an energetic wild
performance of some of the icons biggest
hit in 1932 a star was born in Macon
Georgia honey he would change the world
through music he was known as the
originator the innovator the architect
and Lil Wayne closed out the in memoriam
segment remembering Kobe Bryant with his
2009 song named after the late LA Lakers
star even Michelle Obama made an
appearance at this year's B et Awards I
am here today to talk about Queen you
know the one yes that's our former first
lady presenting fiance with the
Humanitarian Award leave it to Michelle
and Queen B to leave us feeling inspired
I want to dedicate this award to all of
my brothers out there all of my sisters
out there inspiring me marching and
fighting for change
[Music]